the second episode of the bad batch is a
smaller adventure compared to the
bombastic debut but it offers more time
to explore some interesting character
dynamics a little further
here's where the bad badge episode 2
leaves the squad and how a big decision
changes two of its members
airing on disney plus just a few days
after the 71 minute long premiere of
star wars the bad batch the series
second regular sized episode
follows the titular team as they meet up
with an old friend clone trooper cut
laquan
it's briefly explained for newer
audiences that cut deserted the republic
army after droids executed his squad
as explained in the clone wars episode
the deserter he realized that he could
live a peaceful uneventful life away
from the war and so cut wound up on the
outer
rim territories planet of seleukumai to
do just that
since cut has experience in laying low
from the authorities it makes sense that
the bad batch gang asks him for help
but when they find him they're faced
with a much more personal challenge
cut laquaine's life on the farm is
meaningful for the clones it proves that
life doesn't have to revolve around
fighting for a cause
cuts main priorities now lie in farming
the land with his wife the
twilek named sue laquan and providing a
happy life for her and her children
shaya and jack whom cut adopted he's a
genuinely kind person who's clearly
willing to help those who need it which
is why cut
offers to take omega in and look after
her as his own
after she escaped kamino and joined the
bad batch at the end of episode 1.
however with the empire's rise to power
and the tighter policing of seleucum i
cut wants to leave with sue and the
children to build a new home elsewhere
it's hardly surprising since cut is
still technically on the run from the
authorities even though he's settled
down with his family
a small moment during an escape later on
in the episode perfectly demonstrates
why he needs to get away as another
clone trooper starts to recognize cut as
a clone
the sheer look of horror on cut's face
at the idea of losing his family is a
reminder that while the clone wars and
the bad batch are animated shows aimed
at children
they also deal with some surprisingly
adult fames
some of the biggest problems in the
second episode of the bad batch are the
new rules and restrictions that the
empire is placing across the galaxy
most importantly the empire is creating
chain codes that can be used to
identify and track anyone living under
the new regime by creating these codes
the empire has made it more difficult to
move around the galaxy for those without
official
documents effectively this is a way to
crack down on people moving between
planets as a way of cutting all chances
of a rebellion or a coup
against emperor palpatine the logic is
that if people stay where they are they
won't have the strength and numbers
needed to overthrow the empire
unfortunately for the baddies things
backfired oppressed citizens rebelled
almost immediately as seen in the series
first episode when saw guerrera's force
is amassed on the jungle planet of
onderon
episode 2 sees the team scrambling to
get cut laquan's family their own set of
chain codes including one for omega so
that she can live a normal life as a
child
it's the first example we've seen of the
squad working directly to help the
citizens of the galaxy in a way that's
similar to other shows like star wars
rebels it's likely that they'll keep
helping those in need as the series
progresses
even possibly joining the rebel alliance
if they survive that long
hunter has had an interesting dilemma
since omega joined the team at the end
of the first episode of the bad batch
he's slowly shifting into a father
figure role but he can't understand why
omega acts
so recklessly even putting herself in
danger when a nexu beast attacks
hunter is used to the military lifestyle
where orders are followed to the letter
but cut and sue are more understanding
children will always find ways of
getting into trouble hunter
it's what they do it's one of the
reasons hunter decides to let cut take
omega with him and his family when they
leave seleucum i it's understandable why
he makes that decision
the bad batch members are living a
dangerous life on the run from the
empire which isn't exactly a
kid-friendly situation to be in
but by doing this hunter completely took
omega's agency from her
cutting off an opportunity for her to
grow up in an environment where she'll
learn how to properly fend for herself
sure her life with cuts family would
comparatively be more comfortable
and safe but in a time where clones have
become much more hostile to normal
citizens who's to say that the laquans
will always be safe
thankfully hunter's decision didn't stop
omega from making one of her own
reclaiming her authority
when omega first meets the laquan family
she's immediately excited to be around
kids her own age
she's allowed to play for the first time
ever since her time on kamino was mainly
focused on working as an apprentice in
the cloning facility
however while she enjoys playing with
shaya and jack
omega keeps coming back to the bad batch
because they're more familiar and safe
to her
even when omega reluctantly agrees to go
with the la queens when they leave
seleucum i it's obvious she doesn't
actually want to be apart from hunter
and the other clones
they formed a unique bond when omega was
on kamino she had no one around that was
like her much like the bad batch weren't
like the rest of the clone army so she
recognized herself in them
thankfully by the end of the bad batch
episode 2 omega chooses which family
she'd rather be in
she leaves the liquaines as they escape
selukimai and she returns to the bad
batch
this is a significant move since it's
completely her own decision
despite hunter originally pushing omega
in the other direction
toward what he believed was better and
safer for her during the final moments
of the episode hunter and omega both
accept that they have a lot to learn
from their unique dynamic
and more importantly that the young
clone truly belongs with the bad batch
on whatever adventure comes next
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the bad battery coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]